hello freak [ __ ] people like Jordan
Peterson and I have major differences
with him on sort of the content of his
ideas not about academia but on academia
he's right completely and I'm totally in
solidarity with him what they did to him
and what they're doing to him we need
more people like him standing up and
saying no I'm going to say what I want
in my classrooms and on Twitter and it's
because that's people have been punished
for that - what they're trying to get
him to stop doing is YouTube which I
know which is fat I know because they're
very measured their long form he gets to
expand on his thoughts as much as he
likes he's very very informed you know I
again I have major disagree
what is the disagreement disagreements
with him on gender and post-modernism I
think he's completely off but you know
how so and Genzo so he and I know you
agree with him on this I think well
maybe I don't know I'm not sure of it
you know it's this idea that there just
are two genders that's it and there no I
don't look good okay he seems to think
that so I think there's a spectrum of
humans in every single aspect yeah in a
person I should say I heard your
conversation with them and I could see
and this was interesting and it was
exciting because I could actually see
you moving in a direction that I found
to be much more interesting than his
which is closer to mine which is yeah
that it this it's we would feminine men
there's masculine women there's highland
yeah okay Thailand right facts speaking
here we go merging all these topics
together one of the top Moyes high
fighters recently on enough she's still
fighting as a [ __ ] mm-hmm Indians you
know well once she became once you got
the operation her performance dropped
off pretty rapidly sure but that's just
lack of testing I know you're saying
about a Fallon Fox yeah and so I agree
with you there so here's the thing okay
a different story I totally agree with
you on that particular thing right yeah
there she should have been allowed to
fight well it's not that she should have
been allowed to fight I think she should
be allowed to fight women as long as the
women know that I used to be a man if I
film was for the first two fights she
didn't disclose it right because she
said it was a medical procedure and she
didn't have to give up the personal
details of her medical procedure I say
[ __ ] right I say well you're dealing
with a chromosomal issue you're dealing
with the factory of a different bone
structure different mechanical
advantages and 30 years of testosterone
in your body it's just not the same
exactly but as long as someone knows
look I'm fine with drain domaine de
round to me she knocked out a man have
you ever saw that I did she's accused
she's not you know oh yes right [ __ ]
bad-ass yes she's just [ __ ] bad-ass
I mean I don't know what if she's taking
anything into her entire career I would
just be pure speculation she doesn't
look like she that doesn't mean anything
either right but she's so [ __ ]
bad-ass and so technical and so tough I
know she's fought men but she knew they
were a man going in she made a decision
just like I think you should be a lot of
skydive just like I think you should be
allowed to ride bulls I don't think it's
smart right we should be able to do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do I'm all
for freedom of expression of
participation and any sort of dangerous
activity my issue 100% was that people
are trying to pretend that there's no
advantage whatsoever
and that's crazy that's silly so the
thing is what they're so within that
framework within the rules we are
operating in right whether it's in
fighting or whether it's in you know
this particular society the wrestling
girl and Rex yeah read all about that
too exactly so those are that's a
particular roofie you're you are
agreeing to play a particular game right
right and you're just breaking the rules
that's all I mean you have you have soil
body well they're adding them break the
rules the rules are not and I think a
lot of it is people worried about being
called transphobic or homophobic or in
any way prejudiced where they're
allowing certain people to compete in
these like this woman in Australia the
trans woman Ostrow that just broke all
these world records in weightlifting
because she was a [ __ ] man her whole
life all sudden became a woman it's just
killing everybody then there's the
runners and I think they're from Kenya
yeah or South Africa another one from
South Africa killer forget her name -
what do you mean the one that's like a
hermaphrodite well I don't know what she
is but she's broken every record by like
you know huge right same amounts I think
she's just a woman with an abnormally
large amount of testosterone I think
they've actually on chromosome tests I
don't know when I saw her in the
Olympics I just yeah things jumped out
at man we pull that up because I'm
pretty sure
that woman actually has been tested and
then there was a real issue behind it
and she felt terrible about it because
it was just the way she was born really
yeah yeah well and respect yeah I cook
there's men what a tremendous amounts of
testosterone there's men that have like
almost none that's actually the major
point we need to talk about you're
totally on the right track there I
totally agree with that that's the most
important thing which is that there's a
spectrum right I'm so to say that there
are that 50% of the world is male and
50% is FEMA a nonsense or man and men or
what right thank you black I said I say
to my students I say okay there's seven
billion people in the world okay imagine
in your mind lining all of them up you
know naked in front of you
how many sexes do you see race is what I
want you to do right get a picture of
Yoel Romero and put it next to a picture
of Andy Dick tell me they're the same
thing
tell me this is even they're both men
tell me it's even it's nonsense
I mean right okay oh yeah I've you know
it's like have you ever heard a guy on
the street say man that's a lot of woman
yeah well that suggests there are women
who are less women today you know
so exactly yeah that's exactly right
there's a spectrum and there's a
spectrum and sizes me that's right let
me add like this okay so let's push a
little further okay so so far you're
doing very well
and your eyes some people are screaming
at their [ __ ] Oh computer leave me I
know welcome Carmy believe me I know
that's going all mo so that's well no I
think you are he are I think you already
went all the way actually I mean so what
there's to think there's there's the
Jordan Peterson view I don't think he
has that hand let me let me put it out
there I mean okay what I think is he's
saying which is that gender is fixed and
biologically determined I'm pretty sure
he does believe that hmm okay that's
what I would call sort of the
traditional conservative convention you
those both men yeah exactly she's or not
or you know what or like there's more
than two categories in the world right
and so Andy Dick would be one and well
you'll be another shoe and I where would
you put me there I mean I'm neither one
of those guys here in the middle air I'm
neither one of them you're well see the
thing to deal is both of them can
procreate with women
okay yeah now I know both met but a
whole lot of people who are called men
cannot procreate with women a whole lot
what do you mean there's a trans woman
no no trans men lady they can't it
doesn't work oh so they don't develop
sperm yeah really yeah of course a
really common yeah I weren't you tested
when when you were trying to get
pregnant no I just knocked her up dude
come on
oh no you I don't need to with Milo but
anyway it certainly was originally not
um in there and watch the firework yeah
see there you go so you're more of a man
you've just proven look yet again again
were a woman yeah Jesus cry when you
yeah that's not a great picture doesn't
give you a sense of how he does a little
bit sighs and the bolt yet is Sheila
mold well three times as high as most
women whoa okay so reports leaked out
that doesn't really mean anything I
don't think she's ever really been
tested I believe she has see if she's
been tested
what is the test set that had leaked she
was subjected to sex verification tests
after she won the World Championships in
Germany and what does it say yellow a
leaked the results were supposed to be
confidential but reports leaked out that
she had testosterone levels three times
as high as most women other intimate
details about her Anatomy were also
reported yeah Samia became targeted
semenya semenya you know how brutal your
first name is seat the first party name
is semen semen became targeted with
abuse on social media but what does it
say this is so is it saying that she's a
hermaphrodite they were talking about
her you know this is the clitoral size
maybe it's the equivalent of pretty much
every article written about Trump by the
New York Times mano eight Abram a report
was leaked by you know officials said
were the actual evidence of any of this
stuff I don't see it what is it it
doesn't say anything other than she
passed the test doesn't matter she must
have passed the test doesn't matter
here's the thing I think see my rule if
I were a woman athlete right yeah um I
would want rules established it's like I
would want rule established defining the
physical characteristics of any of my
potential opponents
right so it could be whatever bone
density muscle mass you know
testosterone levels
you name it you you you could probably
speak to this better than I could but
I'm sure there's all sorts of ways you
could actually define that pretty
precisely and you can test those things
you can say okay you get to be in this
it's like weight classes and fighting
it's no different really right I mean
you're not allowed to fight someone
who's thirty pounds lighter than you are
and what you could do that in any sport
you could say right if you're above a
certain height or above a certain weight
or have this much muscle or that much
testosterone you're not allowed in this
category there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing sexist about that
there's nothing anti-trans about that
it's just a different kind of but that's
all that matters right that if that is
the problem was that Fallon Fox had as
you said more muscle more testosterone
all these physical characteristics that
were fundamentally different than all of
the other women fighting in that
category in that particular game that's
all you got to do well the problem is
that you can do damage to the purse I
know it's not as simple as I'm playing
basketball you can someone who had more
testosterone
it's terrible to do that there's also
like there's a type of thinking that's
involved in discussing this where the
you you have to follow a line of
thinking and if you don't follow I think
of your transphobic you're a hateful
person you're a bigot and that line of
thinking is not science-based it's just
not when you when you talk to
board-certified endocrinologist so they
talk about trans people one of the
things that they talk about is the fact
that when you take estrogen it actually
maintains bone densities the reason why
they give estrogen to women who have
osteoporosis so this idea that your bone
density decreases when you go from being
a man to a woman it's [ __ ] you're
taking testosterone your bone density is
going to stay the same or get thicker
but if you're taking estrogen your bone
density is also going to maintain it's
going to help you maintain so when you
remove the body's ability to produce
testosterone its own it was a whole
article in
Bloody Elbow of an MMA by this
board-certified endocrinologist dr.
Ramona critic and what she did different
than everything else all these other
articles is she's not a gender
reassignment surgery
okay all these other people that are
commenting on this have a vested
interest in it being completely neutral
there's all these people that are trans
people that are commenting on it and
they're doing it from a very biased
perspective because we're not talking
about mountain biking which there was a
woman who used to be a man who dominated
mountain biking and it became a giant
issue with people who they first
supported her and then she was winning
by such enormous margins they were like
what the [ __ ]
same as the woman in Australia that the
weightlifter this is different this is
fighting and I think fighting you know I
almost killed that woman she beat the
[ __ ] out of a few girls but then she
lost Ashley Evan Smith who is a
biological female you know so it's you
can beat someone like that was again
Ronda Rousey probably beat the [ __ ] out
of most 135 pound men in the world where
she meets of course you know it's just a
matter of skill level it's no different
than peds like banning peds we want to
do that right right yeah I'm saying it's
altering the body's chemistry its
abilities right and so you don't want to
compete against someone because of that
difference unless you know right
limiting saying and then you can say or
unless you're allowed to do the same
thing then it's all fair but but you
couldn't you woman would have to take
testosterone and balance it out and then
you'd have to find out how would you
balance out 30 years of a body naturally
producing testosterone increasing your
ligament strength releasing a tendon
strength yes oh there's mechanical
advantages of male hips are very
different when it comes to kicking when
it comes to certain types of movement
women's hips go out and then their legs
kind of come in at an angle and it's not
not the best for kicking it's not the
best for a lot of different activities
right different so I would just say that
a trans woman is absolutely in my view a
woman fine you know I don't that's their
identity and I respect that however they
want to identify and because the
category of woman as you said is so
fluid you know let I'm not going to say
there's any absolute about that either
that it can change and it's you know
comes from her ideas right I still I
respect that and I'll call you a woman
I'll treat like a woman but that means
we have to change the sports right and
we have to have just different
categories instead of yes woman sports
and man sports we need to have and women
and man category
in those sports we need to have
different categories that are about
people's physical composition now what
you're made up of right so it's just
like weight classes and PE D there's no
difference to me well or there could be
the argument that a person a trans woman
is a woman but when you're talking about
athletic competition you're talking
about a very biological thing I'm saying
if you might have to say that someone
has to be a biological female to compete
again I'm saying to take a gender out of
the sport right if you take that if you
stop calling as gendered names then it's
definitely not true a trans issue hmm
it's just about what your body's made up
of so firend olanta to just weight class
like Germaine to random a is Prato broad
Ralphy more likely it's probably made up
just physically more like closer to a
man closer to yell Romero than Andy Dick
how dare you she's going to find this
and she's going to find you
gosh I hope so someone likes to be hit
it really choked out real fast yeah so
so that means I would just say you know
there should be a category you know of
in the sport you know for people who are
made up of that composition and that
could be people the Society identifies
as men and or who identify as women or
whatever oh man that's a that's a
slippery slope why there's a lot of work
there yeah it is like what I mean how
would you define it what parameters
would use bone density well you know a
lot of african-american women have
similar bone density to white males does
that mean you should be able to fight
black chicks maybe yeah it depends right
so well no actually they kind of are
doing it and well being with you up to
say oh man
I'm not messing man well even though
she's like what 60 years old 60 50 you
could crush me no but I mean they are
doing it in fact we just saw this with
what's-her-name caster cemaat samanya Oh
what are they doing with all this it's
the thing about testosterone level what
do they do actually the aggression with
her no there's there's a number for
testosterone that you have to be below
right to compete in that sport as a
woman so that's that's what I'm talking
about just add more categories not just
testosterone you have to have that's
what this says okay it says roster on
goes above a certain level you're not
allowed to compete as a woman so I'm
saying have that category and add more
categories like that and don't call it
women and men just
at category X you get to compete in this
category if your testosterone androgen
yeah but what they're saying no but it's
so ridiculously loose it's saying a
female with hypo and drogyn ISM who is
recognized as a female in law shall be
eligible to compete in women's
competition athletics provided that she
has androgen levels below the male range
like I have to do is just be like a
couple notches below the male range
which is way above but I'm saying
objectively determined you can do that
you're trying to get her to take
suppression medication or subtly exam
okay this is all proving my point that
these are objectively two terms what I'm
asking her tone it down we have numbers
right we say if you hit this number for
this category you don't get to compete
here but this is so is so rare I mean
she has a disease essentially where she
produces too much to stop it would apply
to trans people's what I'm saying right
so if you but would it because even so
you're still dealing with the mechanical
advantages of the male frame the wider
shoulder especially comes to hitting we
could do that too you know wait we do it
with weight already why not
Wow height sure boy in fact a lot of
works out there I thought about that
right having equal look I'm sure you up
to like in weight classes right like I
have a huge advantage I always use it
I'm 6 1 165 and I have really long arms
mmm so like most of the time people
can't get inside my job like I just put
it out there they can and it's just a
thing is it but it's an often feel like
this isn't really fair in a way you know
I don't have to be as good as they are
mm-hmm I can be looser and it's true for
a lot of fighters but once they get
inside on you they have an advantage
like Mike Tyson use that advantage of
being 510 on a lot of fighters an
advantage I think he just was really
good at overcoming it hmm I think
they're gonna get away in fighting and
having shorter arms and he did any lower
he did the peekaboo past the jab maximum
I really really well really but he did
that thing as did Rocky Marciano Danny
what he had a really good way of getting
in slipping the job and moving
constantly until he was inside on him
and then he would crush you with his
huge left hook but once he's there he
doesn't have an advantage on you he's
just there and he's Mike Tyson but you
don't
it's harder for a guy with the long-ass
spider arms to punch a guy who is in
tight on you with short arms and is
throwing shots to the body like Tyson
with you oh I don't think so
I think there's advantages as long as
you're like physically confident there's
advantages in particular movements and
positions to all sorts of different body
styles it's very true in jujitsu guys
with long arms and long legs and you
have massive advantages with chokes you
guys can get Darcys and guillotine and
triangles easier but you can also get
armbar these here there's mechanical
advantages and arm barring you there's
there's there's some weird advantages to
being like a Jew smart Paul hores stocky
short guy here's basket how about
basketball there you go oh it's all
advantage okay tall right and in fact
there are leagues not actually there
might be professional leagues which are
you know six feet and under leagues
brilliant yeah
mini lead Oh NEP this is very common
because most people are under six feet
tall right so who could never play in
the NBA even though they're amazing
basketball players but they just don't
have the arm length and they don't have
the height and all that that's
interesting so we just need more
divisions the UFC should have like you
know welterweight should be there should
be Heights within it - I say it almost
was only five nines is occurring Isiah
Thomas he's a new layer for the number
one he's and Johnny Hayes he sees a lot
of guys that are under six but though
he's a great great player around six
foot they get listed higher - did they
cheat and interest
he's exists so he's sort of the
exception that proves the rule he's five
nine but he's really well you bet mother
- double yeah it's funny like we have
six or somebody three five three mug he
was five three and dunked didn't I
didn't I was it five seven but no I'm
pretty sure mugs you'd ever pull it up
Jenny jamesgu another way that's why
it's my wheelhouse around lawyer and
you're in Jamie's wheelhouse in a big
way right here's your monkey but I'm
sorry doc okay Mugsy Bogues he may not
have been a super clean dunk but it was
a duck let's see 10 photo let's see if
he dunked we go with a video that's my
life goal was to say pull it up Jamie
Webb okay this about Webb Muggsy does it
have a video of him dunking I don't
think so I never seen it my god we're
gonna want a Google Mugsy play
yeah well I'm told Mugsy Bogues dunk he
didn't Google the home right there it
was great and Mugsy Bogues dunk
Jamie number two on Google hood say I
watch this I've never ever seen this in
my entire life dude he just that's not
oh that's not a video game that's
probably not real yeah isn't a video no
it really did I promise you in me a life
is my memory is that it wasn't a clean
super clean dunk but he did get the ball
above the rim with his hand on it we're
gonna get to the bottom of this ladies
and gentlemen shame you'll get to the
business different pretty essential if
we don't solve this failure but there's
a big difference I think between team
sports where you know you could have an
advantage of having a spud Webb or a
Muggsy Bogues very mobile agile kind of
guy who can set plays up versus guy like
Shaq big giant guy who can you know get
in the way of things and I think there's
all sorts of advantages and
disadvantages at size when you're
talking about individuals against
individuals that's where things get
weird and then when you're talking about
combat sports that's where like people
have just true there's some people that
just have these tremendous advantages
like you know Paul Daley is mmm
ridiculous power like almost unfair like
he hits guys and just obliterate yeah
but you know that's not just strength so
Nick yes yes
yeah mm-hmm and it's all it's also
geometry body geometry yes right yes a
lot of skinny dudes like me have power
some yeah a lot yeah right and a lot of
big Tommy Hearns is the best ample right
a bunch of them but he's also like this
wide and then his waist is like this and
this angle just right I thought it's
tore actually I've actually thought its
shoulder width yeah I thought I'm saying
yeah you get as wide yeah and oh you
like this and so there's the shoulders
like that the torque yes exactly I mean
it's great more to swing yeah that way
yeah for sure wide shoulders a rotate
around High Line yeah yeah often times
equate especially when they learn
striking sports at an early age you
learn how to develop that snap and
fluidity tennis and a lot of
muscle-bound guys don't don't wait yeah
I they do they have a thinking or I want
you to go talk to Dana and get this get
this going we need to height divisions
we need we need testosterone
you know division to competition or
level division and estrogen level
divisions I think we're
are literally one generation away from
being able to use CRISPR and all these
new genetic engineering tools to make
people whatever style of person you want
I think you're going to be able to
develop six-foot-four super athletes
that look like Anthony Joshua or Vitaly
Klitchko or Vladimir Klitschko you're
going to be able to make those now what
I would give for Bionic knees right when
you guys are [ __ ] up or never I'm not
there okay they're they're problematic
that I can I can function fine but they
could go out and any time yeah I mean if
you've never worried about that and you
never had to worry Brian can you imagine
well if you could just redo that I'm
telling you what they were talking about
before the podcast what they're doing
now with stem cells with soft tissue
injuries it's tremendous I mean it's
really amaze never happened before what
they're able to do to people that have
meniscus injuries is literally shoot
stem cells in there and you regenerate
meniscus tissue I mean that's just never
happened before and I think that this is
baby steps I think what we're at right
now is really really young I think 20-30
years from now because twenty years ago
they didn't really use it at all twenty
years from now I think it's going to be
insane people I mean they regenerated a
woman's bladder using her skin tissue
they built her a bladder she had bladder
cancer they built her a bladder and then
reinstalled it in her body now she was a
functional bladder that came out of her
own body they regenerated yeah I think
you're gonna be able to do that with
tendons and ligaments and all sorts of
tissue I believe it and hopefully this
is really promising they're going to be
able to do that with brain tissue so
people that have had brain injuries
people that have had CTE they're
hopefully going to be able to use some
of these therapies to regenerate brain
tissue Wow yes that's huge neurogenesis
is like that's that's the promise God
bless them you know I don't know
anything about science I'm just a
complete idiot when it comes to math and
science but man just go for it and by
the way as far as universities you know
I'm I am the harshest critics of
universities generally but mostly what
I'm talking about it actually the
humanities and social sciences when I do
that what goes on in the biology
building the chemistry building the
physics building I don't know but I know
that what comes out of them is a better
life for me right and all of us right
there making this stuff
we talking about and so go for it and so
you know renegade universities not we're
not going to do no science we're going
to let we're going to let Harvard and
MIT keep going have at it guys you know
because you're doing great stuff I have
no critique of that as far as I know
there's nothing going on there that's
wrong but it's just the humanities and
social sciences that are utterly corrupt
we got way off the track here what we
were talking about initially was Jordan
Peterson well yeah disagree with him
when I got gender and what you agree
with him when it comes to the
suppression of expression of professors
and all people worried about being
called racist and sexist and anything
else
stifling free speech so what he's facing
is even worse than what goes on in the
United States in a sense in that it's
it's now legal persecution he is
actually you know it's against the law
to not use these gender pronouns in your
class which is that suppression of
speech that's suppression of academic
freedom it's a complete violation of
those things in fact and that's that's
totalitarian I mean there's nothing no
two ways around it my uncle at Canada
has these these laws yeah right they
have a human rights commission I think
it's called or human something Human
Rights Council Council and they'd it's
like a body of people who sit there and
decide who should have a website or not
and my uncle this actually happened to
him about ten years ago he was accused
of being a Holocaust denier because and
I don't even know exactly what he was
saying on there but he's a Ukrainian and
I think he was sort of just defending
these Ukrainians who were accused of
being Nazis during the World War two
I don't know doesn't matter even if he
were a Holocaust denier he should have
his website right the Canadian you go to
that URL it's shut down in effect they
put a banner now it says this is now
like controlled by the Canadian
government or something oh oh yeah no
they have no free speech in Canada I
mean there's no there's no sort of
doctrine legal or otherwise in Canada of
free speech it's bad and that's what
Jordan Peterson spacing it's because
he's Canadian this would not happen in
the United States until of course you
know the sociologists take control and
then they will have these laws but we
don't have them here so he actually
could go to prison that's what's that's
what's happening he could go to prison
for not saying sir in his class there
was an article that vice publish that
someone linked to me today
this that I did not read yet because I
announce that Jordan is going to be
returning to the podcasts and someone
was saying that his interpretation of
these laws is greatly exaggerated see if
you could find that it's a very recently
vais article I'm pretty sure it's
illegal and illegal means you can go to
prison ultimately I think Jordans wrong
and I don't think it exaggerated because
that matters a lot to me horse yes yeah
I am a hundred percent in solidarity
with him on that and he's completely
right that the state no one should be
telling him to what to say in his
classroom and certainly shouldn't be
going to prison for it or being
threatened in any way legally he was
just a fine a fine right people don't
understand this it's incredible how
people don't understand that everything
the state does is enforced by the threat
of ultimate violence right so my mother
even said this recently she said no it
doesn't it there's no violence with
parking tickets they just send you a
fine I said oh really so if you get the
fine and you don't pay it what happens
when we get another notice and then
another notice right mom and then
another notice and then finally what
happens
Corinne gains this black woman in
Maryland a couple years ago this is
exactly what happens you've got a bunch
of traffic tickets and she's refused to
pay them and ultimately what happened
the SWAT team came to her house and and
she pulled a gun and should they shot
her in the head that was over traffic
fines okay that's what happens that's
what it means to make something illegal
at the end of the day for the for it to
be meaningful as a law the state has to
use lethal violence to enforce it or the
potential for lethal in other words if
you don't pay your taxes even if it's
you know a hundred dollars in taxes
ultimately otherwise the law is
meaningless right right they have to eat
they have to put you in prison or kill
you
[Applause]
[Music]